[Musica]
ciao a tutti questo mio lavoro come
molti di voi magari potranno pensare non
solo uno sciampista ma in questo istante
stavo ponendo sul capo di questa ragazza
un elettroencefalogramma e ragnetto che
vedete nella nella slide il motivo per
cui utilizzo determinate tecnologie
determinati strumenti nella mia vita
lavorativa
lo scoprirete nel corso di questo
viaggio che faremo assieme nei prossimi
quindici minuti è un viaggio che parte
da molto lontano dall'infinitamente
grande per arrivare a molto vicino e
all'infinitamente piccolo sicuramente
avete riconosciuto la via lattea la
galassia di cui fa parte il nostro
sistema solare
sapete quante stelle alla via lattea
circa 250 miliardi numero inimmaginabile
vi faccio vedere questa slide e invece
sapete cos'è questa è una rielaborazione
grafica ovviamente di quello che il
tessuto cerebrale di cui è composto il
nostro cervello
qui dentro ci sono 86 miliardi di
neuroni e una quantità altrettanto
grande di altre tipologie di cellule
ogni neurone
tenete conto questo si collega l'altro
con un migliaio di sinapsi cosa vuol
dire questo che all'interno del nostro
cervello
vi sono più connessioni sinaptiche più
cellule rispetto alle stelle della via
lattea tutto qua dentro
ok perché vi parlo di cervello io mi
occupo di neuromarketing e sono un
appassionato allo stesso tempo di
cervello e di marketing
noi tutti noi abbiamo siamo guidati
guidiamo una macchina pazzesca che
appunto il nostro cervello per
affrontare il viaggio che faremo oggi
avete bisogno di affrontare alcune tappe
la prima è quella di sapere che il
nostro cervello può essere suddiviso in
tre parti la prima cervello antico
rettiliano governa i nostri istinti è
completamente rivolto alla preservazione
della specie fa battere il nostro cuore
ci fa respirare non è sotto il nostro
controllo
se voi vi ritrovate all'interno di
questo tunnel
non potete non provare una sensazione di
pericolo cervello intermedio olimpico o
emozionale che mi piace molto di più qui
dentro vi sono delle parti che sono
fondamentali per catalogare i nostri
ricordi e per elaborare le nostre
emozioni
vi faccio un esempio ricordi emozioni
sono correlati tra loro
se vi chiedo dove eravate il 18 maggio
del 2003 nessuno di voi proventi se lo
ricorda
ma se invece vi chiedo dove eravate
l'undici settembre del 2001
io mi trovavo da mia nonna come tutte le
donne guardano solo rete 4 non so le
vostre la telenovela la sua telenovela è
stata interrotta dall edizione
straordinaria del tg4 mi ricordo come
ero vestito stavo facendo i compiti ero
piccolino com'era vestita lei cosa avevo
attorno
questo perché l'emozionalità negativa
approvata in quell'istante ha incollato
all'interno del mio ippocampo
quell'organo la parte a forma di cazione
di cavalluccio valino nel nostro
cervello che è responsabile della
memorizzazione dei ricordi
voi non potete non provare tenerezza nel
vedere questa foto
anche perché vi si attivano i neuroni
specchio i responsabili dell'empatia
non potete non provare sensazioni
diverse nel vedere quest'altra slide ma
questo perché perché la percezione della
realtà è filtrata dai nostri sensi e
dalle nostre esperienze
la mia esperienza la vostra esperienza è
completamente diversa quindi provate
sensazioni diverse
ultimo ma non ultimo la nostra corteccia
cerebrale è quello che ci fa essere
unici umani
se io vi chiedo quanto fa 16 per nove
potete decidere se fare o meno questo
calcolo ma non avete non potuto provare
tenerezza non avete non potuto provare
una sensazione di pericolo prima vi
faccio una domanda quindi cosa sono le
emozioni una domandona di definizioni ce
ne sono tantissime cos'è la rabbia la
rabbia è il pre risultato di un'azione
fallace erronea che voi molto
probabilmente non ripeterete nel corso
della vostra vita
cos'è l'ansia non si è fondamentale per
l'essere umano
l'ansia di mantiene in allerta delle
possibili minacce questo nel breve
periodo nel medio lungo
l'ansia si traforma in stress non siamo
strutturati per sopportare lo stress e
quindi è deleterio
ma soprattutto cos'è la felicità e vi
presento giulia alla mia ragazza e asia
al mio cagnolino di 40 kg la felicità è
il risultato di un'azione di successo
che probabilmente voi ripeterete e
ripeterete e ripeterete percorso della
vostra vita ma quindi cosa sono le
emozioni
c'erano filoni di pensiero che ritenevo
le emozioni un bloccante della nostra
vita del nostro percorso
le nostre decisioni se noi proviamo
dello stress nell'acquistare un
determinato prodotto
magari ci blocchiamo avrà per questo che
sono state ritenute un bloccante ma vi
ho appena dimostrato contrario le
emozioni sono un fattore qui tante del
nostro percorso di vita sono anche un
fattore responsabile delle nostre
decisioni e con esse anche delle
decisioni d'acquisto
questo io vi do il benvenuto nel mio
mondo nel mondo del neuromarketing dove
si utilizzano strumenti stranissimi come
li hai tra chi gli occhialini che
addosso la ragazza in grado di
monitorare e registrare il movimento
oculare si utilizza il ragnetto che
avete visto prima dall'altre cefalo
gramma per capire il coinvolgimento
positivo negativo nei confronti dello
stimolo di marketing per che cos'è
neuromarketing il neuromarketing ai
connubio tra neuroscienze che è la
scienza che studia nostro cervello il
nostro sistema nervoso autonomo e del
marketing marketing tradizionale gli
strumenti ce ne sono tantissimi c'è il
fascia the condition chelsea e sar ma
non è questa la sede per spiegarvi lì
perché neuromarketing perché il
marketing ha bisogno di fare questo
salto di questa evoluzione il marketing
si basa sulle ricerche di mercato quindi
su dati pressoché quantitativi su
ricerche di mercato basate su interviste
strutturate semistrutturate o su
questionari serve ma cosa che accomuna
tutti questi strumenti
quando voi cliccate in determinate bo
indeterminato bottone di un sito la
vostra mente è già andata lì il vostro
occhio è già andato lì quel click
voi l'avete già razionalizzato le
ricerche di mercato a tradizionali si
basano sulla razionalizzazione ma adesso
vi dico questo considerate il volume
dell'infinita rea kat definita rea come
al contenuto del nostro cervello quindi
il vostro viaggio prosegue riducendo via
livello atomico
siete in questo momento dentro a un
marasma di neuroni e si connettono
elettricamente l'uno con l'altro siete
quasi dentro un cielo stellato pieno di
stelle cadenti sapete quanta parte anche
in percentuale è parte razionale conscia
di cui avete controllo quante invece è
parte inconscia di cui invece non avete
il controllo questa pressappoco è la
vostra parte razionale quella di cui
avete il controllo
questo signore qua elabora 40
informazioni ogni secondo
sapete quante informazioni elabora il
nostro cervello anni secondo 11 milioni
quindi siamo più guidati dalla nostra
parte inconscia o dalla nostra parte
conscia cos'altro ci dice questo che
siamo estremamente selettivi sulle cose
a cui prestare attenzione l'attenzione a
livello cognitivo è una delle cose più
rare che abbiamo il 95 per cento delle
decisioni delle nostre decisioni circa e
con esse anche le decisioni d'acquisto
viene preso irrazionalmente il motivo
per cui voi allungate la mano su uno
scaffale e decidete un profumo piuttosto
che un altro è perché magari avete visto
due tre settimane prima
lo spot pubblicitario di quel profumo ma
voi non ve ne rendete conto
non hai che siete tutti controllati il
neuromarketing vi aiuta a scegliere il
prodotto giusto per voi il
neuromarketing p per me permette alle
aziende di costruire una comunicazione
coinvolgente quello che è fondamentale
capire è che per costruire una
comunicazione fantastica incredibile è
necessario muovere tutti i tre cervelli
che vi ho detto prima è necessario è
necessario avere l'attenzione del
consumatore
la sua attrazione è necessario quindi
avere il suo interesse ma poi ci deve
essere un processo di analisi queen a
una conferma logica razionale per
completare un acquisto
questo viaggio prosegue con un ulteriore
ingrediente che vi da tutti voi io
compreso in questo momento sono il
risparmio energetico come gli smartphone
che avete in tasca
il nostro cervello non è in grado di
reperire tutte le informazioni per
prendere una decisione che si era più
efficiente ed efficace in quel
determinato istante ma quindi cosa fa
crea delle scorciatoie delle scorciatoie
mentali queste scorciatoie vengono
definite anche distorsioni cognitive
byas cognitivi beneceto qualcuno se vi
chiedo quanti abitanti all'indonesia
l'indonesia ha più di 100 milioni di
abitanti i temi un numero probabilmente
le risposte che avete dato la prima
domanda sono rispettive se rispetto a
quelli che avete dato alla seconda
domanda ma cosa ho fatto io in questo
momento vi ho ancora potuti il nostro
cervello in mancanza di informazioni si
aggrappa a quella che ritiene più
affidabile per il contesto creato ma
l'indonesia 222 milioni di abitanti
l'avreste mai detto portiamo tutto
questo in ottica di marketing un capo
d'abbigliamento in un ecommerce che da
300 euro passa a 150 i 300 euro sono
barrati cosa succede
il vostro cervello sia ancora sui 300
euro si attiva il percorso il processo
di auto gratificazione all'interno del
nostro cervello viene prodotta tra le
altre cose della dopamina e noi siamo
più spronati ad acquistare quel prodotto
semplicemente perché veniamo premiati
anche dal risparmio che percepiamo
ultima camera disponibile per la
destinazione selezionata per le date il
che hai selezionato il 90 per cento
delle strutture è occupato questo è un
altro vayas cognitivo leva della
scarsità siamo più attratti da ciò che
riteniamo raro
della scelta se vi pongo davanti dieci
possibili alternative
poi probabilmente decidete di non
scegliere questo perché di fronte a
tante scelte l'essere umano in costante
risparmio energetico preferisce no
grazie
ma se io mi pongo davanti tre
alternative ecco che voi siete più
predisposti a continuare il vostro
percorso decisionale e anche il vostro
percorso d'acquisto ce ne sono di
vescogni tv ce ne sono un'infinità e
sono in costante evoluzione
uno degli ultimi nati al cosiddetto
search engine effect secondo cui
soprattutto le nuove generazioni tendono
a non memorizzare più determinati tipi
di informazione perché tanto ci sono i
motori di ricerca
posso sempre inserire in una chiave di
ricerca all'interno del motore e
comunque l'informazione cielo vi voglio
lasciare facendo vi presente cosa
innanzitutto nel mio mondo nel
neuromarketing nelle neuroscienze non è
mai il consumatore oggetto d'analisi
essere oggetto d'analisi è sempre e
comunque lo stimolo di marketing
lo spot pubblicitario il packaging il
sito web che si sta navigando
tenete conto inoltre anche di un'altra
cosa
cito antonio damasio che una lo
scienziato portoghese perché secondo me
riassume il cuore del neuromarketing
motivo per cui il marketing ha bisogno
di questa evoluzione
noi tutti noi non siamo macchine
pensanti che si emozionano ma siamo
macchine emozionali che pensano
io vi ringrazio per avermi donato in
questi quindici minuti la risorsa più
rara che avete la vostra attenzione
grazie
[Applauso]